مرحبًا أيها الأمريكيون ، لقد كان أعظم
شرف في حياتي
أن أخدم كسيدة أولى للولايات المتحدة ،
لقد ألهمني
الأمريكيون الرائعون في جميع أنحاء بلادنا
الذين رفعوا مجتمعاتنا من خلال
لطفهم وشجاعتهم ،
لقد كانت السنوات الأربع الماضية
لا تُنسى
بصفتي دونالد وأنا أختتم وقتنا في
البيت الأبيض ،
أفكر في كل الأشخاص الذين
أخذتهم إلى المنزل في
قلبي وقصصهم المذهلة عن حب
الوطن والتصميم ، أرى وجوه
الجنود الشباب الشجعان
الذين أخبروني بفخرهم
أعينهم كم يحبون خدمة
هذا البلد لكل فرد من أفراد الخدمة
ولعائلاتنا العسكرية
المذهلة ، أنتم أبطال وستكونون دائمًا في
أفكاري ودعواتي ، أعتقد أن جميع
أعضاء تطبيق القانون الذين يحيوننا في
كل مكان نذهب إليه
في كل مكان.  ساعة من كل يوم يقفون فيها
حراسة للحفاظ على مجتمعاتنا
آمنة ونحن إلى الأبد في
عمقهم لقد تأثرت بالأطفال الذين
زرتها في المستشفى
أطلب من
كل أمريكي أن يكون سفيرًا له ليكون
الأفضل
للتركيز على ما يوحدنا لترتفع
فوق
ما يفرقنا لنختار دائمًا الحب
على الكراهية
والسلام على العنف والآخرين قبل
أن تكون متحمسًا في كل ما تفعله ولكن
تذكر دائمًا
أن العنف ليس هو
الحل أبدًا ولن يتم تبريره أبدًا